leyrit parrish installe une pancarte
qu'il a réalisé avec sa femme
on y voit un grand coeur et quelques
mots pour dire que les victimes ne
seront jamais oubliés
c'est difficile d'imaginer que ça a pu
arriver dit il
il y à un va et vient constant de gens
qui apportent des fleurs ou encore des
peluches des photos des drapeaux le lieu
de commémoration de paul topix a grandit
de jour en jour tout près des véhicules
de police bloquent la route menant aux
scènes de crime les enquêteurs qui
travaillent encore pour tenter
d'élucider c'était compréhensible
tragédie d'ailleurs cet après midi ils
ont organisé une battue dans le secteur
l'enquète n'est pas simple
le tireur a mis le feu à plusieurs
résidences dont la sienne il ya eu des
incendies apporte à pic
mais ailleurs aussi dans d'autres
communautés où il a fait des victimes
ça demande naturellement parce que là
bas plus de travail parce qu'il va
falloir retirer les différentes strates
des différentes couches de pollution de
contamination volontairement mise dans
lequel présent de l'incendié et le temps
joue contre l'anc est un jeu de monsieur
claude pinault la météo par exemple
pourrait effacer des traces de la
tragédie
josette d'entremont a fabriqué ces
petites oeuvres avec du verre retrouvés
sur les plages
sa façon à elle de vivre ce deuil
collectif en cause de coven on ne peut
pas se toucher on ne peut pas
s'embrasser et je pense je ne sais pas a
que les familles pensent la même chose
qu'eux ils ne sont pas tout seuls et et
tout le monde est lent pour eux en ces
temps de pandémie
les neo et que c'est font ce qu'ils
peuvent pour trouver du réconfort
la distanciation sociale rend le deuil
encore plus pénible alors si moment de
recueillement sont de minuscules bombe
sur leur immense peine et si michel brix
de radio canada